with a man trying to help his son
through some really rough times that man
ended up dead and just hours ago the
search for the man's son came to an end
good evening to you thanks for joining
us i'm brian loftis and i'm denise
valdez continuing on with this story a
30-year-old justin gaines was arrested
in fact just a few hours ago now last
night his father 56 year old roy gaines
was found dead inside justin's home near
tropicana and boulder highway that's
where we find joe moeller now as the
investigation continues to unfold in the
relationship and what went wrong joe
a lot of neighbors in this area were
waiting to find out if the suspect was
behind bars well we learned he was
arrested near the arizona new mexico
border and is being extradited back here
to las vegas to face that one murder
charge now here's a look at the house
where this all happened the garage is
actually now boarded up from yesterday
but neighbors say it was pretty hectic
out here but they're glad to know that
someone is now behind bars
i feel for the family neighbors on
sageland street are still trying to wrap
their heads around what happened it's
just sad what happened yesterday i mean
we were just all
taken by surprise with the amount of
police that was here and then the
command trucks came and swat metro says
wednesday roy gaines was found dead in
this home they also say he came from
northern california to visit his son
after concerns about his mental state
after communications stopped the
victim's wife and other son came only to
discover his body the suspect was gone
metro says justin gaines was arrested
thursday we see him passing by daily and
walking his dog this is a photo from the
department of corrections website from a
previous conviction this neighbor who
called 9-1-1 wednesday did not want to
show his face i kind of locked myself in
my room with the knife just in case he
ran into my house because you never know
he tells me this was not the first
problem here court records show gaines
pleaded guilty to a charge of attempted
battery with substantial bodily harm he
was released on his own recognizance by
judge michelle levitt gaines was
supposed to be sentenced for that crime
in january now neighbors say their
concerns will linger i do i do have a
lot of questions
now back out here live it is not known
what led up to the shooting inside of
that house we do know that the father
was visiting his son from northern
california reporting live this evening
joe muller live local now